House Democrats launched a formal
impeachment inquiry of President Trump
charging him with betraying his oath of
office and national security by
colluding with a foreign power this
sounds familiar
I don't this worked very well for
Democrats last time so I'm sure this
will work just as well again but as
president Trump comes under fire for
asking Ukraine to investigate Joe Biden
another letter comes out from last year
Senate Democrats wrote it asking Ukraine
to investigate president Trump huh but
that's two years after then Vice
President Joe Biden pressured Ukraine to
fire a prosecutor investigating his son
for corruption all of which leaves
Democrats with a tough political case to
make they want to impeach President
Trump for acting like a Democrat we will
examine the fallout
then with clowns to the left of Trump we
take a look at the Joker's on the right
one of whom is called for the president
to be executed on national television
all that and more
I'm Michael Knowles and this is the
Michael Nolt show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
before we get started today and there is
obviously a lot going on Democrats make
a an official formal move toward
impeachment using that word impeachment
but first I have got to thank my friends
over at plex Adam you know I've lost a
little bit of sleep last week or so I
don't know you know listen I work very
hard I do everything I can I give it all
to you the audience if you have a
wrinkles on your face or bags under your
eyes and I do have bags under my eyes
join the club I'm usually there because
I don't sleep enough now imagine that
you can reduce those bags dramatically
imagine those those bags relatively are
almost entirely gone the solution is not
surgery or anything like that it is plex
Adam a clinically studied serum that
visibly eliminates your wrinkles crow's
feet and under-eye bags in minutes don't
believe it I didn't either until I tried
it I've got to tell you folks when you
see me when I'm not here on the show
when I'm not using my plex Edurne when
I'm not in the bad olden days not only
did I have under eye bags my under eye
bags had under eye bags they were really
really bad they were really really
noticeable Plex adjournment really does
help it's terrific it can give you the
confidence you need to be your best at
work and with your friends and get this
Plex Edurne goes on clear so nobody will
know that you were using it go to Plex a
durham comm use my code Noll scan Oh
wles for 50% off plus an additional $10
off 50% off plus another 10 bucks that's
right 50% off plus an extra $10 off this
offer is available also by calling 1-800
605 1292 and mentioning code Noel's ko
wles Plex the derm is backed by a 30-day
money-back guarantee visit Plex a Durham
calm today and use code Knowles at
checkout ko WL e s that is triplex a
Durham calm so some big news out today
House Democrats are opening an official
SuperDuper official formal impeachment
inquiry doesn't mean they're voting on
impeachment but they're using the word
official and the word formal and they're
using the word impeachment from Nancy
Pelosi's lips for the first time she's
been holding off on impeachment she's
been pushing back on impeachment now she
says they're taking steps toward it now
they're trying to make it sound bigger
than it is because it's not like they're
actually voting on impeachment right now
but they are taking steps in that
direction and that is a big change here
is Nancy Pelosi's announcement they
asked Benjamin Franklin what do we have
a republic or a monarchy Franklin
replied a republic if you can keep it
stop it there before we get to what
she's actually saying I have to just
point out that Benjamin Franklin said we
have a republic if you can keep it and
Nancy Pelosi pretty much replied that we
can't keep it so we're gonna try for the
third time to remove the sitting
president who was duly elected by the
American people I love when Democrats
invoke the founding fathers this is the
they despise the founding fathers they
hate everything they stand for they call
them white racist men sexist bigoted
idiots awful terrible people
except when they want to use one or two
quotes and the best part is they use the
quotes about how we need to protect our
Republic while at the same time they are
completely undermining our Republican
form of government but Pelosi she
doesn't just stop there with quotes of
Benjamin Franklin she goes on to invoke
the Constitution you know that document
she loves so much our responsibility is
to keep it our public indoors because of
the wisdom of our Constitution enshrined
in three co-equal branches of government
serving as checks and balances on each
other our wonderful Constitution that we
love so much are wonderful checks and
balances which is why we've outsourced
all legislative power to the federal
administrative state and to the Supreme
Court and why we love the Constitution
so much that's why we have repeatedly
infringed on your second Amendment
rights we basically don't even
acknowledge your second Amendment rights
it's why we're infringing on your First
Amendment rights it's why we constantly
infringe on your ninth and tenth
Amendment rights and it's
why we've invented a completely
fictitious constitutional right to
redefine marriage at the federal level
and to kill babies in the womb because
we love the Constitution so much that's
why we ignore all of the rights and
structures of the Constitution and why
we completely rewrite it without going
through the formal process of rewriting
it and invent rights that don't exist
because we love the Constitution so much
because we're the left because we're the
Democratic Party great job Nancy bring
up the founding fathers and the
Constitution two things that you hold in
such high esteem and that I'm sure would
hold you in such high esteem
she then finally gets to the meat of the
announcement and she gets to the
horrible terrible nefarious actions
undertaken by the president that call
for impeachment the actions taken to
date by the president have seriously
violated the Constitution especially
when the president says article 2 says I
can do whatever I want for the past
several months we have been
investigating in our committees and
litigating in the courts so the house
can gather all the relevant facts and
consider whether to exercise its full
article 1 powers including a
constitutional power of the utmost
gravity approval of articles of
impeachment it is a constitutional power
of the utmost gravity which is why we
have been clamoring to use it since
before Donald Trump even got elected or
once he was elected but wasn't sworn
into office and we've been doing it for
the past three years that's what's so we
take it with such seriousness and such
gravity that we already
clamored to impeach him for a scandal
that didn't really exist which is
colluding with Russia that we found out
wasn't true because of the Bob Muller
investigation for two years and then we
talked about doing it because he slept
with a porn star and paid her off and
they said it was a campaign finance
violation and even though Barack Obama
committed egregious campaign finance
violations we were going to impeach
Trump for it and then we're gonna do it
because of a phone call the president
Trump allegedly had with the Ukraine
will - of what he did have the phone
call but because of the allegations from
the phone call we'll get to that in just
a second and so we're taking it really
SuperDuper seriously so we're gonna then
with such gravity we're going to
exercise our impeachment powers by the
way the phone call happened in late July
this
came out in August that that late August
there was some trouble September there
was some trouble so it isn't that
they've been following these very formal
serious grave processes for years and
years you just got a phone call that you
think you can use to impeach him two
months ago
that's the gravity but then she gets
even more specific it's not just that he
makes a comment here and there and not
just that he had a phone call with
Ukraine she gets really specific what
did Trump do to justify impeachment and
this week the president has admitted to
asking the president of Ukraine to take
actions which would benefit him
politically the action of the truck the
actions of the trump presidency revealed
dishonourable fact of the president's
betrayal of his oath of office betrayal
of our national security and betrayal of
the integrity of our elections therefore
today I'm announcing the House of
Representatives moving forward with an
official impeachment inquiry all right
it's official it's official because
President Trump was using the government
to try to benefit himself politically
well we'll get into the actual
allegations here we'll get into the
phone call we'll get into some other
unfortunate news for Democrats that have
come up after the transcript of that
phone call came out but I just want to
address impeachment generally before we
get into it generally speaking I am
against impeachment I mean I support
impeachment as a provision of the
Constitution I like that there is the
possibility of impeachment to hold the
president accountable but I think
impeachment should be reserved for the
rarest and rarest of circumstances and
it should entail crimes committed by the
president that rise to a very very very
high level and in recent times it has
been incredibly overused I don't think
it should have been used against
President Johnson in the 19th century I
don't think it should have been used
against Richard Nixon or threatened
against Richard Nixon in the 1970s it
was used against Bill Clinton actually
largely because of Democrat overreach on
the Nixon impeachment threats President
Nixon was elected and he was reelected
with an overwhelming majority of
Americans Democrats never got over it so
they found that he he didn't tape a door
correctly and they
after him for that other presidents past
presidents past Democrat presidents had
done many many worse things but they
didn't invoke impeachment they went
after Nixon for impeachment because they
couldn't bear the thought that he was
re-elected because of that overreach you
started this really ugly process of
hyper partisanship and hyper
politicization you saw this then in the
Bork confirmation hearings for the
Supreme Court under President Trump that
was run by Democrats you saw that and
what they did to Clarence Thomas that
assault was run by Democrats and so
after these repeated abuses of power by
Democrats in the government you had the
Clinton impeachment
which basically said we're not going to
unilaterally surrender and let you guys
run roughshod over our republic even
then I see the argument for the Clinton
impeachment and the guy did commit a
crime even then it was politically
disastrous for Democrats and it should
not be used against President Trump for
any of the alleged misdeeds that they're
they're bringing up now the trouble is
in Washington DC you could indict a ham
sandwich this is true in DC this true in
New York is true in Los Angeles you can
always find some little infraction
especially because our federal code is
so convoluted now especially because you
know half of us are committing crimes on
a weekly basis that we probably we don't
even know our crimes
the question is does what the president
has done rise to the level of
impeachment we will analyze it I don't
think there's a very good paid case for
that whatsoever
impeachment should be reserved for
moments of genuine national crisis for
truly high crimes and misdemeanors so do
Trump's actions rise to that level we
will see he released a transcript of the
phone call that Democrats want to
impeach him over it's five pages long
I've read the whole phone call I was
against the release of that phone call
from the start because I think it's bad
for statecraft I think it's bad too for
the office of the presidency regardless
of what party holds that office
I think foreign leaders should feel as
though they have some at least relative
degree of privacy and and a discretion
when they're on that phone call and
unfortunately that has now been
obliterated I think was a bad move to
release it politically I think it's good
for Trump to release it so it's out
there why
does it say we'll get to that in one
second but first I gotta thank our
friends over at Quicken Loans it's very
difficult to find a house in LA very
very difficult because you find a nice
house and then it costs 20 zillion
dollars and you know they don't they
don't pay me enough over here you know
it's very difficult when the left is
going after you it's very difficult to
to really get all your income streams
going the right way so when I do find a
house I'm very happy because at least
finding the right mortgage will be easy
because rocket mortgage makes it easy
their mortgage experts number-one goal
is to make the home buying process
smoother for you
industry-leading online lending
technology rocket mortgage is there with
award-winning client service and support
every step of the way
it's ranked highest and customer
satisfaction for primary mortgage
origination nine years in a row highest
in mortgage servicing six years in a row
when you work with them you get more
than just a loan because rocket mortgage
is more than just a lender it's really
terrific when you go in to buy a home
for the vast majority of people that is
going to be the biggest financial
decision you ever make in your life
don't go it alone don't go with second
best or third best go with the number
one go with the best get started online
at rocket mortgage comm slash Knowles
Canada wles
Equal Housing lender licensed in all 50
states n MLS consumer access debt org
number 30 30
rocket mortgage by Quicken Loans push
button get mortgage so what's the
transcripts a 30,000 foot view the phone
call is nothing it's nothing I'm not
saying it's not interesting I'm not
saying there isn't some President Trump
wants something and Ukraine wants
something but that's politics I mean
that's the whole point of these phone
calls is one country wants something
another country wants another thing
countries are led by politicians
politicians have interests there is a
difference between using statecraft to
advance your personal interests and
using statecraft to advance legal
interest or even political interest or
certainly national interest we'll get
into that distinction too but I'm I'm
just saying not from the perspective of
the nitty-gritty of this law and this
code and this action and this regulation
I'm just saying politically speaking
this transcript is nothing but
it's even better than that because it
highlights actions taken by Democrats
multiple actions over the last three
years that are not merely the same not
merely just as bad but actually
significantly worse so let's get into it
broadly speaking you can read the letter
you said early they transcript yourself
rather it's about five pages long I
think it opens with the two presidents
flattering each other so Trump says Oh
congratulations on your election that's
so great and then the Ukrainian leader
says oh yeah we learned a lot from you
you're we used your tactics we love
talking to you so it's nice friend
friendly friendly President Trump then
brings up election interference in 2016
he brings up the firing of the
prosecutor in 2016 the prosecutor who
was looking into corruption by hunter
Biden Joe Biden's son and he mentions
the relationship of the Obama White
House and Joe Biden to that and then he
brings up the Muller investigation all
perfectly reasonable aspects of
statecraft it's reasonable because the
2016 angle relates to the American
election it relates not just to the
Obama White House but it relates to Joe
Biden who's a prospective candidate
major leading politician so the reason
this is important is because it now
appears there was some election
interference from both Ukraine and
Russia obviously Ukraine and Russia or
at war with one another of Russia's
invading and annexing parts of Ukraine
so this is a hotly contested political
situation the American election is the
most important election in the world
everybody's involved everybody's trying
to push it in the interest of their own
nation so it stands to reason and it
makes perfect sense that well Russia is
trying to push the election one way
Ukraine might be trying to push the
election another way that's for another
day that's for you could talk about that
for hours then on the phone call Ukraine
brings up a rudy giuliani
this is very very important because what
we were told in all of the media early
media reports that I told you we're
gonna BBS is that Trump mentioned that
Ukraine should talk to Rudy Giuliani
Rudy Giuliani is the president's
personal lawyer he's not the White House
Counsel so this was the smoking gun that
the media were looking for if Trump
instructed the Ukraine brings up Rudy
Giuliani and says you got to talk to him
then this looks like a campaign
this looks like a personal matter this
does not look like a matter of
statecraft and so it looks corrupt but
what we see from the transcript is it's
a Ukraine that brings up Rudy Giuliani
they say we love Rudy Giuliani we want
to talk to him we want to meet him that
is key then Ukraine by the way when he
they bring up Giuliani Trump says oh
yeah he's a nice guy he's a really great
guy so most of what he's talking about
with Giuliani it's just the kind of
absent-minded flattery that the
president keeps on a lot of people then
Ukraine says they will look into the
prosecutor issue which they should I
mean the Ukrainian leader more or less
implies that the prosecutor who was
involved in letting Jojo buy the Sun off
the hook was politically motivated might
have had a little more going on which
anybody with two brain cells to rub
together knows that this is true
why else would Joe Biden go in and
threatened to withhold a billion dollars
in US aid to Ukraine as they're fighting
a war with Russia if there wasn't
something serious on the line there for
Joe Biden even bragged about it at the
Council on Foreign Relations
so the Ukraine leader says okay we're
gonna look into this even says that the
new prosecutor is better and he'll make
sure that the prosecutor under under his
watch will be will be much better then
Trump says he'll have Rudy Giuliani and
Attorney General William bar call it was
requested that Giuliani called by the
Ukrainian leader so checks out
importantly here though
if Trump is saying good I'll have bill
Barr call then you're involving the DOJ
in this whole event in this whole phone
call in this whole investigation
importantly Attorney General Bard did
not call there's no evidence he was
directed to call so it does seem like
you get a lot this kind of idle chatter
from President Trump yeah yeah we'll do
that we'll do that don't worry it'll
happen fine Kimberly stressfull who is
an excellent journalist and writes for
The Wall Street Journal she summed it up
well on Twitter she pointed out the only
ask that actually occurred in this phone
call from Trump to Ukraine is the
Ukraine look into the interference in
American affairs the relationship
between Ukraine in the United States in
2016
perfectly legitimate ask then what
people are not
getting from this transcript because
it's not included in the transcript is
the phone call that we're talking about
was on July 25th at this point the
Inspector General was referred this to
the DOJ referred this asked on looking
into Joe Biden the son to the Geo day as
a DOJ is a possible campaign finance
violation Trump using the government to
advance his own campaign
the DOJ already looked into this it's
not like this is a totally new issue
this happened two months ago the DOJ
looked into it and what the DOJ
concluded quote all relevant components
of the department agreed with this legal
conclusion that there was no violation
already been looked into IG already sent
it over you're good worse yet speaking
of the Inspector General the Inspector
General who referred this matter over to
the DOJ found that the so-called
whistleblower who leaked information
about this phone call in the first place
had quote some indicia some sign of an
arguable political bias on the part of
the complainant in favor of a rival
political candidate hmm this is pretty
interesting
so the whistleblower codeword for a
leaker the leaker here had a bias in
favor of a political rival of President
Trump is it Hillary Clinton or is it Joe
Biden perhaps that's pretty interesting
if he had that bias than what you're
really looking at is not president Trump
colluding with the Ukraine it's the DOJ
colluding with the Democrats again not
the DOJ the intelligence community
colluding with the Democrats again which
they already we're doing in 2016 so the
more things change the more things stay
the same so then the story of Trump's
alleged corruption again you'll look a
little more deeply they're using it and
trying to turn it into a trump scandal
when really it is a left-wing scandal
but it gets so much worse than this so
much worse for the left so much better
for us what this means is that the
Democrats are impeaching President Trump
for something
brought up by a partisan Trump opponent
that has already been cleared by the DOJ
here is president Trump's reaction to
the whole thing and if you take a look
at the Democrats they went down to see
the president of Ukraine and they asked
him for all sorts of things and don't go
with the Republicans and stay with us
and like it's a political war they
shouldn't have done that and that should
be an impeachable event I guess based on
what you're saying the Democrats just
came out they went down there a group of
people some of whom I was dealing with
and the gun issue and they went down put
tremendous pressure on Ukraine the
president himself just came out with a
statement saying there was absolutely no
pressure put on him and there wasn't
what I do want to see is I want to see
other countries helping Ukraine also not
just us as usual the United States helps
and nobody else is there so I want to
see other countries help just so you
understand it's the single greatest
witch hunt in American history probably
in history but in American history it's
a disgraceful thing the letter was a
great letter meaning the letter
revealing the call that was done at the
insistence of myself and other people
that read it it was a friendly letter
there was no pressure the way you had
that built up that call it was going to
be the call from hell it turned out to
be a nothing call all right I love this
response there's a lot to get into in
this response I would like to correct
the President on one bit though he did
say one thing in this reaction that is
untrue he said that what he's
experiencing is the greatest witch hunt
in history and that is not true actual
witch hunts are the greatest witch hunts
in history the Salem witch hunts and
witch trials are probably I just say
they're greater because they involve
actual witches or Atlee I guess at least
allegations of witchcraft so anyway
that's just sort of a technicality I
would say the Salem witch hunts greater
witch hunts than this one this one's
pretty close though and everything else
the guy said was completely correct what
you heard in the very beginning of that
clip is he said Democrats were making
demands of Ukraine they
shouldn't have done it by the premises
of the left on my impeachment inquiry
though the Senate Democrats also
committed an impeachable offense and
it's funny because he mentions that
right off the bat he comes out there
with it and then he kind of lets a trail
off and talks about all these other
things and said that the left bought
into the media's idea that this was a
call from hell and then it was a big
disappointment and the Democrats should
have overplayed their hand and now it's
gonna work to my political benefit the
most interesting thing in the whole
statement is he said the Democrats made
demands of Ukraine that by the very
logic of the impeachment inquiry against
me are impeachable offenses against them
so what did they do we just learned this
is how much better it gets
we learned that Senate Democrats asked
Ukraine to investigate President Trump
they made the same ask of Ukraine for
their political opponent that they are
alleging President Trump made of his
political opponent except their
political opponent is the President of
the United States so their their matter
was strictly political or rather
president Trump's matter is strictly
political what President Trump is
alleging of Joe Biden for instance is
that the matter was both political and
nepotistic it involved his own son and
then the Senate Democrats come and make
the same political charge against Trump
I have the letter printed out the letter
it's a beautiful letter huge great
lovely letter oh my gosh I'm just
getting so excited even Trump's
vocabulary is seeping in because
christmas came early for president Trump
today May 4th 2018 so when the letter is
dated this is a letter from Senate
Democrats to the general prosecutor of
Ukraine yuriy lutsenko dear mr.
prosecutor general we are writing to
express great concern about reports that
your office has taken steps to impede
cooperation with the investigation of
the United States Special Counsel Robert
Muller so you remember this was about
the Muller investigation which turned
out to be ooop absolutely nothing
but at the time Ukraine was important
because Ukraine
didn't have a role in the 2016 election
and because Ukraine had a long history
with Paul Manafort who was president
Trump's campaign chief for a short bit
of time okay the letter goes on and
they're all worried about the Muller
investigation if they had known it would
come to nothing they probably wouldn't
have even sent the letter because the
letter is kind of incriminating for them
here's the key to the letter we
respectfully request that you reply to
this letter answering the following
questions
has your office taken any steps to
restrict cooperation with the
investigation by special counsel if so
why did any individual from the Trump
administration or anyone acting on its
behalf
encourage Ukrainian government or law
enforcement officials not to cooperate
with the investigation by special
special counsel Robert Muller was the
Muller probe raised in any way during
discussions between your government and
US officials including around the
meetings of President Trump and
poroshenko in New York in 2017 signed
Bob Menendez who is who federal
prosecutors think paid underage
prostitutes repeatedly Pat Leahy US
Senator and Dick Durbin u.s. senator all
major Democrats the key here is not
number one is interesting but number two
and three because in number two and
three with the Senate Democrats are
asking is that the Ukraine government
investigate their political opponents
exactly the same thing that they are now
trying to impeach president Trump over I
don't really understand the logic of
impeachment I have a few thoughts on it
which we'll get to in a little bit but
maybe I'm just trying to put logic on
people who do not have a great capacity
for logic they apparently don't realize
that by issuing this impeachment inquiry
they are implicating themselves in a
crime if what Trump did is a crime then
what they did is a crime and it's not
like they can hide the crime they put it
on paper they put it in a letter that I
managed to get but it was sent over a
year ago absolutely mind-boggling
stupidity and incompetence now look the
impeachment inquiry is being launched by
the house I bet if it were to be
launched by a bet if the Senate
the ability to launch it they probably
wouldn't along [ __ ] because it looks
pretty bad now the left is trying to
downplay all this stuff all the Biden
investigation all of the equivalents all
the pointing out the parallels between
the Democrats and the Republicans here
it isn't working we'll get to that in a
second then we'll get to a whole lot
more we'll get to president Trump's
reaction to all this well and we'll get
most importantly to what this means for
2020 plus a poem that I just discovered
that I think is gonna be perfect
christmas came early for president Trump
with this impeachment inquiry and I
think I've got the perfect Christmas
card that he can send out we'll get to
all that in a second but first you got
to go to daily wire.com and check out
our new website we have a brand new
website up it looked really sleek and
really cool ten bucks a month hundred
dollars for an annual membership you get
me you get the andrew Clavin show you
get the Ben Shapiro show you get the
Matt Walsh show you have to ask
questions in the mailbag coming up
tomorrow and I'm sure they're gonna be
great I can't wait for the mailbag
tomorrow you can ask questions backstage
you can get another Kingdom you get
everything and you get the leftist tears
tumblr oh how important that is that's
gonna be all the more important every
day this impeachment inquiry goes on get
the tumblr don't drown go to daily wire
calm we'll be right back
the best part of this whole thing is
that what Trump and the Senate Democrats
did both of them because what they did
is about the same Trump in the Senate
Democrats but it's not nearly as bad as
what Biden did what Biden did for his
own son and for his own prospect
prospective presidential campaign while
Biden was the sitting VP you know what
he did he already admitted it he went in
threatened to withhold US aid from
Ukraine at a crucial time for Ukraine if
they didn't fire the prosecutor who was
looking into his crook drug drug addled
degenerate son hunter Biden and he
pushed the issue he got the prosecutor
fired and then it completely
unprecedented
he insisted on approving the new
prosecutor in a foreign country in the
Ukraine hears Biden in classic Biden
fashion accidentally admitting to all of
it I went over I guess the 12th 13th
time to Kiev and and I was going
supposed to announce that there was
another billion dollar loan guarantee
and I had gotten a commitment from
poroshenko and from yachts anouk that
they would take action against the state
prosecutor and they didn't so they said
that they were walking out to Prescott
said no I said I'm not gonna go or we're
not gonna give you the billion dollars
they said you have no authority you're
not the president the president said I
said call him I said I'm telling you're
not getting a billion dollars I said
you're not getting a billion I'm gonna
be leaving here I think it was about six
hours I looked I said believing in six
hours
if the prosecutors not fired you're not
getting the money Oh son of a put in
place someone who was solid someone who
was really solid who was going to excuse
the actions of my generate' crooked drug
addled son so the left is trying to
downplay all this Biden stuff right now
because Biden is still or you ibly the
Democratic frontrunner but it isn't
working watch this exchange this is such
a beautiful exchange to highlight
Democratic leftist media bias on NBC and
how they're doing the classic Democrats
strategy of saying this is old news this
has been investigated don't worry about
it stop bringing it up and Republican
Senator Joe Kennedy ain't havin any of
it here is the exchange
you do realize
a lot of people have attempted to look
into this and they haven't found it
they're there to look into it and that's
the point here you had up the yeah let's
look into it apparently the Ukrainian
government apparently every every base
entertaining and journalists plenty of
people here we'd all looked into it I'm
sorry
yes sir you do realize you're looking
for an outcome not the facts that's what
you keep telling me no there have been
four or five different entities that
have found nothing here who I just told
you and they're not good enough to you
and they're not good enough yet wait you
said your cry said Ukrainian journalists
have the Ukrainian government has
apparently if the FBI has been contacted
the FBI can't seem to open an
investigation either because they
haven't found enough myself we've looked
into it the New York Times has looked
into it I'm look maybe you're right
maybe there's magical missing
information here but at some point do
you not accept all of these entities
looking into it to have found the answer
so this is what they do this is what
they do they say we have we have on tape
Joe Biden admitting to this crooked deal
and we have a lot of other documents to
show it then what the left-wing media
says is there's no now people looked
into it that was a while ago people
looked into it and it's cool who looked
into it that's what senator Kennedy is
asking who looked into it you you guys
are total crooks you're totally in the
tank for the left and four for Joe Biden
yeah yeah no we looked into it we look
we looked into it it's no big deal
well who else looked into it Oh like I
don't know like five or six entities or
some fights probably like a hundred
entities I don't know can you name them
yeah and you know Chuck Todd can't name
them so he uses the word apparently
because he doesn't want to get caught in
the lies because apparently Ukraine
looked into it oh the hand-picked
prosecutor the Joe Biden threatened to
withhold a billion dollars in aid from
Ukraine if they didn't pick that person
looked into it and it cleared Joe Biden
okay it's great beautiful that's
terrific well who else looked into it I
don't know the FBI probably and then
Kennedy asks did the FBI look into it
and Chuck Todd can
I don't know yeah I'm just I was just
talking I'm just a guy who talks on TV I
don't what do i I don't know any facts
and who else who else okay yeah we we
like looked or something I don't know so
they got nothing they haven't looked
into it at all it was totally brushed
under the rug they thought they were
gonna get away with it and now they can
you know how you know by the way that
they know this Joe Biden can't answer
any questions for it here's Biden we
don't rumpus it's time to let the world
know who we are
thank you very much all the reporters
you have any Ukraine are you gonna talk
about Ukraine nope you just walk in
right past them this shows us an
important lesson about the left and how
to handle them the left does bad things
sometimes heinous things they abuse
government power they try to overturn
elections they have a national policy of
killing babies and they exploit children
then when you call them out for it
they conflate calling them out for the
crime itself
so they conflate when they do something
bad and then you call them out for it
they say that's the same thing it's
morally equivalent but they're not so
when you call them out for abusing their
power with a foreign country for
political advantage they accuse you of
doing that by the very fact of calling
them out for it but there's no moral
equivalence there's no equivalence
between what Biden did and what Trump
did trying to bring Biden to justice for
what Biden did those are not the same
thing that's are the opposite actually
when you call out the left for
exploiting little children especially
vulnerable children for political
advantage they accuse you of exploiting
vulnerable children there is no moral
equivalence between those two things
between what the left does to children
and calling out the left for what they
do to children Trump owes the left no
apology at all for this call
conservatives oh the left no apology at
all for calling out their disgusting
behavior which they have undertaken on a
whole slew of issues all around the
globe recently and for a long
the lesson of the Trump era is to stand
firm and the left will shatter and the
serious conservatives have learned that
lesson it's a good lesson to learn you
can watch them shatter Joe Biden walks
away he just they say hey what about
Ukraine just one simple question what
about Ukraine he walks away he's walking
he's walking away from his campaign is
what he's doing you asked them that one
you just stand a little firm they they
fall apart
so what's Trump's reaction Trump is
celebrating this Trump released an ad
based on this impeachment inquiry the ad
begins it says Democrats have one goal
they've always had one goal that one
goal is impeachment here's the ad we
begin impeachment proceedings now and
we've got to impeach him and get rid of
them must so focused right now is to
make sure that he's not the president
next term we're going to launch an
article three impeachment in the
question of impeachment it's about time
Nadler is I hope he's not following the
rules Congress to take the steps towards
a pizza and we're gonna have to
prosecute this we're gonna have to do it
we're gonna have to impeachment is still
on the table
absolutely it's always on the table we
cannot accept of a second term for
Donald Trump
if we don't impeach this president he
will get reelected it's time to stop
this nonsense they think they're gonna
win the did you see the one man he said
it's the only way we're gonna beat him
in 2020 they have to do this the only
way they go that's a compliment I guess
but think of what he said it's the only
way they're gonna beat me and actually
it's working the other way cuz now we
have our best poll numbers that we've
ever had nobody is happier than Trump
about this impeachment inquiry this is
Christmas come early for President Trump
and nobody is less happy than Joe Biden
I mean this is really bad
for Joe Biden that's why he's not
answering a lot of questions on it I
assume it's gonna be pretty bad for
Senate Democrats too which is why
they're pretty quiet on it it's really
just the House Democrats who were very
happy about this and the House Democrats
are happy about it because they don't
really have that much to lose and their
careers are ahead of them there they're
not really in this fight right now
anyway it's a bad look how's Joe Biden
taking at big winners is the Elizabeth
Warren Biden is tanking in the early
state polls he's now down in Iowa he's
down in New Hampshire
he's even down 18 points in South
Carolina since May 18 points very bad
news very bad news because Biden's whole
argument is electability so the minute
you lose Iowa first caucus state that
electability argument pretty much falls
apart maybe you could try to drag it
along until New Hampshire maybe
different candidates when Iowa New
Hampshire he's falling down in New
Hampshire too now what Biden is going to
try to do if he loses Iowa New Hampshire
is he's going to try to say look that
doesn't matter what matters is I'm the
only candidate with black support who's
a serious candidate Bernie Sanders
doesn't have any Elizabeth Warren
doesn't have any so if they win Iowa New
Hampshire doesn't matter because the
Democratic candidate simply cannot win
it is not mathematically possible for
the Democratic candidate to win if they
don't do very very well among black
voters and so Biden is gonna say forget
about until we get to South Carolina
South Carolina is the first state that
really has a sizable number of black
voters especially in the Democratic
primaries so that's where I'm gonna win
except he's down there too he had so
such overwhelming support that he's
dropping and he's still doing okay but
down 18 points since May
very bad South Carolina is the firewall
if he keeps dropping there the
electability argument is completely dead
and the Biden campaign is completely
dead if it isn't already because turning
away from those Biden polls in his early
primary state polls looking at the
national polls which again and it's too
early to look at national polls but they
do tell you a little bit about momentum
Warren is up for the first time in a
national poll in the Quinnipiac poll
she's up on Joe Biden
she's at like 27 he's at like 25
she's also tied with Joe Biden in
another poll the YouGov poll I don't
think these are outliers I mean first of
all you don't really have two outliers
like this on on the heels of each other
and they're both reputable polls cute
back and you gov so the momentum appears
to be in warrens direction and Biden's
hurt has not even really begun I mean
we're just starting to talk now about
this Ukraine Biden issue we're just
starting to talk now about hunter Biden
which left wing magazines have worried
is going to tank Biden's campaign since
the very beginning months and months ago
how about when people start to find out
about the Ukraine scandal how about when
the impeachment inquiry if it does go
anywhere starts bringing up all of
Biden's past issues
I wondered why they're bringing this up
now because they'll get like two news
cycles out of this two weeks of news
cycles probably out of this impeachment
thing but it's going to fall apart what
Trump said in that phone call is not an
impeachable offense it's not even close
so why wouldn't they wait until closer
to the general election to bring up
impeachment and then you just get all
the negative news and maybe it pushes
the election one way or another but it
doesn't you don't get to the punchline
which is Democrats don't have anything I
think the reason for it is more about
Joe Biden I think they've given up on
Joe Biden the only person who really
stands to lose here is Joe Biden House
Democrats have already shot their
credibility that's done so if they lose
again you know what if they are the boy
that cried wolf again and again and
again Joe Biden though this nothing is
certain in politics but this almost
certainly destroys his campaign
I think they've given up on him and this
is one easy way to take him out
and you don't have to worry about
holding off on impeachment because of
Joe Biden because they don't have faith
in him in the first place
turning from the people on the left of
Donald Trump to another person on the
left of Donald Trump but who is
ostensibly on the right just take a look
that the anti Trump Republican
candidates for president the primary
opponents appeared on MSNBC of course to
discuss their campaigns we are told by
the benevolent betters of the erstwhile
conservative movement that Donald Trump
is not a real conservative
we hear this from a small group of
people they say Trump's not a real
conservative sure he's had more
conservative policy than any president
pretty much in history and sure he's
advanced our agenda much better than any
of our past presidents in recent history
but he's not a real conservative and so
that's why we need to vote for someone
else and the candidates they've put up
or pretty weak candidates joe walsh who
i actually like but one-term congressman
and a radio host who is Trump e'er than
Trump if the whole argument is don't
vote for Trump you know Joe Walsh has
said some pretty incendiary things and
he's admitted to saying racist things on
Twitter his words not mine
you've got bill weld who's a liberal
Republican I think he was governor in
the early 90s of Massachusetts that was
the last time anybody ever thought of
him and you've got mark Sanford who
abandoned his office as governor of
South Carolina to flee to Argentina with
his mistress then lied about it for a
couple weeks and then I then finally
came back left office and actually got
reelected to Congress these are the guys
these are the jokers these are the guys
that we're told they're the true
conservatives capital T capital C trade
mark over the s true conservatives well
here's one of the true conservatives is
going to restore the rule of law and
dignity and integrity or politics bill
weld calling on national television for
the execution of the sitting president
talk about pressuring a foreign country
to interfere with and control a US
election it couldn't be clearer and
that's not just undermining democratic
institutions that is treason it's
treason pure and simple and the penalty
for treason under the US code is death
that's the only penalty the the penalty
under the Constitution is removal from
office and
might look like a pretty good
alternative to the president if he could
work out a plea deal those are the
serious guys
what we were coming to realize is
everybody criticizes Donald Trump
because he speaks loud and he says
things that are sometimes hyperbolic and
he's not polite and he's kind of a boor
and so they don't like him because of
that he's not mature he's degrading the
office of the president any of the
people running against him
would degrade the office of the
President
far more than he does any of them Joe
Biden is a crook who doesn't believe in
anything who's a cynic who used state
power to threaten to withhold military
aid to help his crook degenerate son in
Ukraine that guy is that's supposed to
be the integrity guy bill weld calling
for the president to be executed mark
Sanford you know I got a I actually have
to put in a word for joe walsh ear
I don't think Joe not endorsing Joe
Walsh I don't think Joe Walsh should be
President I don't think he's gonna win
but in Joe Walsh's defense whatever you
think about him at least he didn't
abandon his office to flee to Argentina
with his mistress or call for the
president to be executed it's like a
pretty good Joe Walsh is by far the most
mature guy of all the people challenging
Trump for the presidency but of all of
them all of them taken together
President Trump appears to be the most
mature appears to have the most dignity
now you might say that's a sad thing
maybe it is a sad thing for the country
but it's a reflection of the country and
as HL Mencken said democracy is the
theory that the people know what they
want they deserve to get it good and
hard and some someone once asked what do
you as what do you think of President
Trump compared to whom compared to whom
elections are about choices President
Trump is looking pretty good right now
he got this early Christmas present from
House Democrats on impeachment and it
reminded me I just want to close on this
this poem because it reminded me of of
Hilaire Belloc who's the one of the
great Catholic writers Hilaire Belloc
would write wrote this little poem in
his Christmas cards and because
christmas came early to president Trump
I think that
he should have these Christmas cards
printed up and he should mail them out I
think I might borrow this Christmas card
and and mail it out when Christmas comes
around as well the poem goes like this
Noel Noel Noel Noel a Catholic Tale have
I to tell and a Christian song have I to
sing while all the bells in a Rundle
ring
I pray good beef and I pray good beer
this holy night of all the year but I
paid attest able drink for them that
give no honor in Bethlehem to Bethlehem
may all good fellows that here agree
drink audit ale in heaven with me and
may all my enemies go to hell
Noel Noel Noel Noel may all my enemies
go to hell
Noel Noel I think that's a pretty good
lesson that we've learned from the news
cycles and particularly today's that's
our show I'm Michael Noel's this is the
Michael Nolt show we got a backstage
live coming up tonight so tune in it's
gonna be a whole lot of fun in the
meantime I'm Michael nose this is the
Michael Nolt show see them
the Michael Noel's show is produced by
Rebecca dabka wits and directed by Mike
joiner executive producer Jeremy boy
senior producer Jonathan hey our
supervising producer is Mathis clever
and our technical producer is Austin
Stephens assistant director pavel white
house key
edited by Danny D'Amico audio is mixed
by Mike or Amina hair and makeup is by
Joshua alvera and our production
assistant is Nick Sheehan the Michael
Noel's show is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 20 19 on the Matt
Walsh show we're not just discussing
politics we're talking culture faith
family all of the things that are really
important to you so come join the
conversation